good morning it's tuesday recently i
went to the hand doctor because my hand
isn't working totally perfectly and he
was like hey do you remember when we
talked about you not signing your name
so much and then you signed 250 000
copies of your book the anthropocene
reviewed and i was like yeah but that
was for work doc and the doctor was like
was it was it for work and i was like
look doc the heart wants what it wants
anyway long story short i have a few
problems but one of them is arthritis
which is terrible news but does have a
silver lining which is that i get to add
to my catalog of itises i'm a heavily
itis person like over the years i have
or have had orbital cellulitis and
eosinophilic esophagitis and viral
meningitis not to mention the
normalities sinusitis gastritis etc but
in this respect i am of course not
unique in our lives most of us will
become extensively familiar with itises
because we have been invited to a very
strange party where you get to have a
consciousness
but it's made out of meat sometimes
people ask me why i write so much about
illness and disease and our historical
responses to them and i guess my
question would be why isn't everyone
writing about it as virginia woolf wrote
120 years ago considering how common
illness is how tremendous the spiritual
change it brings it becomes strange
indeed that illness has not taken its
place with love and battle and jealousy
among the prime themes of literature and
not just in literature historical
narratives also tend to focus on kings
and wars and political philosophies and
whatnot but disease is a terribly
important historical force maybe the
most important one like it's almost
certain that in the last 2000 years more
people died just from tuberculosis than
died from all wars combined and before
you think like oh but that's ancient
history no more people died last year
from tuberculosis than died in war and
every year going back to world war ii
around 93 of all humans die from disease
a phenomenon so common that we attribute
these deaths to natural causes although
for the record there is nothing natural
about the fact that people die of
cholera in haiti but not in the united
states or the fact that poor people in
the united states are almost twice as
likely to develop heart disease as rich
people and so i write about disease and
our responses to it from ocd and turtles
all the way down to plague and the
anthropocene reviewed because there is
this terrible and strange circumscriber
of consciousness and i don't think we're
talking enough about it and also the way
we talk about it matters like let me
give you a weird example itis means
inflammation and so as a suffix itis
refers not to the bacterial or viral
infection itself but to the body's
attempt to deal with that infection or
in the case of autoimmune diseases like
esophagitis the body mistaking healthy
cells as threats and this is really
interesting to me for somewhat personal
reasons like i got orbital cellulitis
because bacteria invaded the soft tissue
between my eye and my brain and then
began spreading out of control but the
name orbital cellulitis doesn't
translate to like staph invaded your eye
socket it translates to your own white
blood cells caused swelling behind your
eye in this and many other ways we tend
to describe disease and illness as
failures or insufficiencies of the body
rather than
literally inevitable side effects of
having a body and so even in these
extremely subtle ways we are prone to
imagining disease as a failure of
oneself a failure of one's biology or
life circumstances or moral choices and
so i think examining the ways we imagine
and understand illness can be really
productive especially in a world where
so much illness is not really caused by
bacteria or viruses it's caused by
poverty and lack of access to clean
water and other human built systems and
i guess in that sense our habit of
imagining disease as primarily being
about human choice is justified not
because individuals are responsible for
their illnesses but because our
collective choices are
hank i'll see you on friday